it's good to have you guys here because
I assume you're in New York for the Rock
and Roll Hall of Fame right oh that
thing yeah is that happening yeah do we
care about that boys yes we do now we do
now yeah we did him for a while no I
have been nominated and inducted you
know chosen yes we care something about
that whole thing the Rock and Roll Hall
of Fame bothers me I inducted Bon Jovi
last year and for many years those guys
were not inducted and they certainly had
sold a lot of albums that had a lot of
success you know if you're in rock and
roll and you sell a hundred million
albums like you guys I would assume you
should be in anything called The Rock
and Roll Hall of Fame but it's it's an
odd thing to put a musician in that
position isn't it it is so what's your
theory so what I mean cuz it is weird so
what's that all about when it comes to
you guys have no [ __ ] clue why they
would leave you out I mean you know
there was a time in my life as a rock
and roll disc jockey
I was playing your songs every third
song you might have been the biggest
band in the world at one point am I
correct I think so I think we take it
personally as well we did yeah you know
yeah and so when 13 years ago you guys
are eligible for the Rock Roll Hall of
Fame I know I know in a way it's silly
but you should have been in am I correct
yeah we didn't know because we weren't
following how it went 25 years and then
you can you came you're eligible to be
nominated we had no idea yeah you know
so it was only roundabout maybe 2007 and
8 when people would start saying well
for the last three years you've been
eligible oh really
yeah and then they would keep asking the
question and we were so fed up with a
question would you say no we don't care
yeah right no it doesn't but it's the
same as the Grammys you know we've no
nominated when we when we had to Dimond
albums to ten times platinum albums
there was no category for us right it's
crazy yeah it's fun in fairness before
the fan vote I think he was a very
elitist thing which is why we kind of
shied away you know if you weren't Lou
Reed or REM or Loudon Wainwright the
third yeah no no not they didn't want is
there's actually a little bit of
snobbery there like it's a judgment call
you're not cool enough to be hanging
with these guys and I don't even
understand that this went out the window
with a fun boat definitely not cold but
the fans liked
but you are cool